da willst du sie lieben freunde ich
denke jeder von euch kennt die
dance team ist das programm schlechthin
wenn man irgendwelche pc-spiele sich auf
dem pc herunterladen will und passend zu
steam gibt es auch eine website namens
im chart auf dieser website werden
nämlich alles teamspieler untereinander
aufgelistet und werden demnach sortiert
wie viele leute dieses spiel spielen
deswegen hatte ich die idee ist golf
aber bis zum ende das hat auch eine
extrem lange zeit gedauert allerdings
bin ich irgendwann hier angelangt bei
den spielen die wirklich noch nie jemand
gespielt hat und davon habe ich mir dann
mal fünf spieler gekauft
zuerst war barro
f-22 es muss anscheinend so schlecht
angekommen sein dass sie den preis
einfach mal um 90 prozent runter gesetzt
haben
es könnte vielleicht einer nervigen menü
musik liegen wir klicken jedoch jetzt
einfach mal auf time trial wählen uns
hier in gelbes auto aus finde ich
eigentlich ganz cool klicken auf play
und ich
fahre ich dann
jetzt gehe ich
das nächste spiel das man aus dieser
zero players liste ausgesucht habe war
elon musk road to respect es kostet 39
cent dafür kriegt man nicht mal der
packung kaugummis und so sieht das ganze
spiel heraus ich weiß nicht was ich
machen soll entgeht nichts es geht nicht
an europa ach so
wir sind also wirklich ihre maske
dürfte es wahrscheinlich nur nicht allen
masc nennen weil das irgendwie rechtlich
verboten weil deswegen sion mast mit tee
genannt und jetzt kann ich hier lang
laufen und muss energie einsammeln ich
befinde mich im weltraum das habe ich
vergessen jetzt gerade im zwei stunden
später
also das macht spaß
[Musik]
ich hab noch 100 hertz
abgeschossen ich versuche allerdings
trotzdem gerade mal wieder neuen
highscore aufzustellen
es kommt nicht mal ein ton wenn ich
sterbe
ach so was kann ich selber schießen okay
das verändert gerade alle ist das heißt
ich eigentlich hat das gar nichts
das spiel bleibt immer noch scheiße die
müsst euch einfach mal überlegen dass
freunde von mir egal
da ich jetzt abschließend kopf schießt
durch und durch was soll das
ich stehe vor ihm nicht rückschließen es
geht durch ihn durch
das was ich einsame ist respekt
ja gut ok weiter geht s
wir machen bei der mitte nächste spiel
kommt und zwar lautet der name ist die
perle glider für 199 und bisher ist das
spiel
ich kann hier mit die farbe manz
paraglider das einstellen ich kann hier
ok ich kann hatte das ist die animation
wenn ich laufe
und wenn ich dann ganz so komisch
denn so komisch egal ob wir schauen dass
man kann ich springe ich kann auch
springen mit space da hinten haben wir
eine stadt das wird vermutlich denke ich
mal aus angel ist einfach gespielt
gefühlt jedes spiel das ändert sich wenn
man berge und sie hat irgendwie immer
mehr
an kontur die
paraglider und mit jetzt meine maus so
komisch und das bin ich
ok klingt es button tutorial
es geht ja noch nein
doch ich denke noch in sind noch
jetzt bin ich tot
und diese auch
gespielt hab neuen highscore ach das
sind alles maps
das sind natürlich alles wir fliegen
jetzt einmal bei kapstadt hier runter
kapstadt ist sehr schön war ich noch nie
wohin
gott dann drehen wir den rücken zu wir
befinden uns hier auf jeden fall gerade
auf dem mount everest in kapstadt wir
kennen ihn alle meine lieben freunde der
stein da unten hat einfach ein loch in
die großstadt darunter das zentrum der
stadt denn das meer die sonne endet gar
nicht erst kommen wenn ich ganz gerne
hochgehe sieht man unsere mit dem
ausland stückchen
ja dass ich mir das ein super spieler
ist 40 cent auf jeden fall
gerechtfertigt hier unten aber dann die
ganzen willen und so hier sind die
missionen die wir sogar haben dropbox
ich wollte eigentlich nur paragleiten
sehen sie können später
ich glaube es ist abgestürzt breiter geh
später hallo
paraglider ich würde dir ein paar bomben
abwirft
hallo
ich hab nichts gedrückt
gut wir probieren sie doch mal wozu
anmerkungen aus dem schnitt ich glaube
das spiel ist ein virus oder
als ich das versucht hat zu fixen und
irgendwelche tasten gedrückt habe habe
ich außer dem shortcut gedrückt dass
mein pc jetzt irgendwie alles ein
bisschen leichter farben anzeigt zum
orangen effekt drauf und der ton ist ein
bisschen los und wenn ihr eine ahnung
davon hat mich das fix und ganz so gern
und danke meiner lieben freunde der
kollege hier ist auch wieder da er dreht
uns wieder den rücken zu allerdings
sehen wir nach vorne schon partner da
rumfliegen und wir suchen uns jetzt
erstmal guten sport aus die vorne direkt
an diese akten stellerin
kann ich jetzt theoretisch einfach
herunter laufen wenn ich angst vorm
fliegen habe
es wäre also ein spiel fehler aber
ich glaube es funktioniert
[Musik]
es geht eigentlich um komme ich fliege
auch das ist ganz normales bringen der
springen einfach so 40 meter weit kann
ich das haus drauf springen will jetzt
dritten mal kann ich jetzt hier
theoretisch tatsächlich fest kann ich
jetzt theoretisch staaten mit dem
fliegen ja
komm hoch
aber zurückhaltend immer noch der erste
platz liegen jetzt noch einmal nach
anderen web und zwar gibraltar eine
ahnung was mich da als erwarten wir aber
warum hängt
aufgebot vor diesem schild aber würde
okay da bin ich meine lieben freunde wie
geht es heute meinen arschloch juckt
perfekt freut mich ja mit zum
allerersten mal so eine richtige
absprung links deswegen werde ich jetzt
zu drücken um zu fliegen und los geht's
ich flieg ich sehe
zu weite guetta ist das letzte spiel ich
klicke jetzt hier einfach mal auf
singleplayer weil freunde habe ich nicht
und jetzt machen wir mal lounge und
ich kann laufen es ist schon mal ganz
gut kann ich durch bäume durchlaufen
theoretisch ja
ok
wo bin ich
den ganzen mist so hayden ziel für
10.000 millionen euro einpacken ach gott
jetzt abgenommen ist ein
bildschirmschoner oder was neid die nach
kommt ich war übrigens ihr falls es
nicht gesehen hat
minecraft auf frisch oder wie also ich
muss irgendwie muss ich jetzt irgendwie
jetzt ist wieder mal dunkler haben soll
der machen wir hier irgendwie beute apa
und irgendwas de and space ich halte was
das tue ich was ist das es
schließt can be found würde und ich kann
das nicht das gar nicht sein oder als
wenn es jetzt sorry aber ich
habs jetzt kommt schatz gemacht
stellte durch das heutige video ist
allerdings auch beenden der lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat was
ich nicht glaube